I would say we've had a lot of times
when we've gone the wrong direction and
we've really picked it up and learned
from it we I remember I T for instance
I've learned more about IT than I ever
want to know but we were changing
systems and we didn't back it up
properly so we had no visibility on what
was shipped or what was received and it
was a six-month problem and actually
social media had a big part in that
because you can imagine that our
customer wanted to know what was going
on so we had to make the decision of how
do we remain authentic really tell our
customer the truth because it was a huge
problem and what we found is by being
truthful and bringing them along with us
they helped us with the problem and they
were very understanding